all right the US housing market is
gaining strength on job growth and
strong consumer confidence in the first
quarter of this year sales of existing
homes jumped to 5.6 million that's up
three and a half percent from 2016 and
the best performance in a decade online
retail estate giant Zillow is reaping
some of the rewards the company
announced record revenue of more than
two hundred forty five million dollars
in March it had an all-time high of
nearly 180 million unique users at its
six websites and apps Zillow Group CEO
Spencer raskov is here with us welcome
back thank you it's great to do just for
everybody doesn't know how Zillow works
what is the Zestimate that we provide
this estimate is Zillow's computer
models opinion of what every home in the
country is worth so you can see what
this estimate is for any home for your
home for my home for your neighbor's
home and that type of information
empowers consumers it helps people make
smarter decisions and what goes into
that calculation a whole lot of math so
when we started about 10 years ago his
estimates had about a 14 percent error
rate and we calculated them monthly on
about half the country today's estimates
have about a five percent error rate we
calculate that in real time
instantaneously on the entire country so
the results but not what goes into what
goes into it is we look at we have a
meta model that sits on top of thousands
of sub models and the sub models look at
everything from proximity to an arterial
to comps to last sale price to tax
assessment $2 per square-foot dollar per
lot square foot the metamodel uses
artificial intelligence to constantly
iterate and constantly learn to figure
out what the right distribution of sub
models are to calculate this estimate
over time and it maximizes maximizes for
accuracy at the census tract level which
is a couple neighborhood blocks well we
put on deep you've got good news and bad
news today and we'll talk about both
let's start with a bad news though
because there's a bit of a kerfuffle for
talking about yours estimates there's a
new class-action lawsuit in Illinois
that says his estimates are misleading
and that the Zillow quote is
unilaterally gathered compiled and
publicly listed properties and
valuations without consent that done
sounds so great for prominent companies
always have kerfuffle zero fellows by
far the most widely is real estate site
by a mile
so these estimates are prominent and not
everybody will always agree with that
but ultimately what a home is worth is
what a buyer will pay for it so the
Zestimate is a great starting point it's
really good information but every home
is worth what a buyer will pay for it
and somebody applies human judgment on
top of this you're not so concerned
about them I'm not it's a frivolous
lawsuit and it'll it's without merit
okay so who are you following that one
yeah so how are you trying to improve
the Zestimate through competition so
today we're announcing the Zillow prize
which is a million-dollar contest to try
to unleash the scientific community's
creativity and computational power and
the idea is anyone who can improve this
estimate will win this million dollar
prize and other companies like Netflix
and in fact I think even just today
Governor Cuomo announced a prize to try
to improve subway safety and subway
efficiency this is a tried-and-true way
of trying to create really unleash
academic input you're going to give
somebody a million dollars at stake if
they can come up with a better way yes
to how you do yours estimates yeah so
bargain to me like well yeah I mean
there's there been so many advances in
the last ten years you just think about
cloud computing for example and
artificial intelligence class started
this 10 years ago all obsessed mchale
queue lations were done by just a couple
handful of computers that we had to own
because there was no cloud now there are
millions of interconnected computers in
the cloud and so the computational power
is lightyears above what it was so hard
hard do you think it's going to be
Spencer to win this million dollars well
what I'm hoping is that people who have
insights from other fields whether it be
self-driving cars or voice-recognition a
lot of the advances in those other areas
use artificial intelligence a lot of the
same technologies that improve this
estimate
yeah and somewhere out there there's a
team of data scientists working on some
other problem that can be applied to
this important problem of figuring out
what homes are worth so I think it'll
happen I hope I hope I get to write that
check for a million dollars to a team of
so AB data's architect for the housing
market over the next 24 you for 24
months it's strong home valleys are very
very strong right now home valleys are
up 7% year-over-year in all regions of
the country um in yeah pretty much in
certain areas home valleys are up 12%
but even the slow markets are still
appreciating a couple points we're now
back at peak value so home values peak
1007 huge decline we're now back past
that peak but it's not built on a
foundation of sand you know the
previously home values appreciate it to
that high level
seven because of a credit bubble now its
inventory constraints there just aren't
enough homes for sale and so it's a much
healthier recovery now than at Oh seven
something tells me I'm gonna have to
write a check for a million dollars
Spencer hope so check I'm ready to
that's ready all right thank you
Thank You Spencer